Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's again. We are going to be talking about
chronic Lyme disease and Lyme disease in general. These first few presentations
I'm going to break this up into multiple presentations
We are this is going to be kind of an overview for anybody that already has Lyme
But I think it'll be a helpful overview and how we look at Lyme disease here in our office
And then we will get into some very deep discussions
In further presentations on current research that's out there
that I will try to
Break down for you and give you the skinny-un some new possibilities for dealing with chronic Lyme disease
You haven't read my book or download my book. Please do so. It would be helpful
As well as any other books that you might be interested in
All right, so it's obviously an unconventional disease
The history real briefly stems back from the 1970s
When some people in the little town of Lyme Connecticut
Hints the name Lyme disease. We're starting to suffer some strange
symptoms
They did not know what caused it and that's where we got the name Lyme disease. Now there's a lot of different theories that surround this
And we're going to go deeper in these in further discussion
One major theory that most
People that struggle with Lyme disease may hold on to is that
The theory of Plum Island. Plum Island is a little island owned by the United States Department of Agriculture now
But it was run by the US Department of Defense during the Cold War
It's right off of Lyme Connecticut
And some of the theories are that during the Cold War
There was experimentation with germ warfare at that facility
Now it is well known that the United States Department of Defense was experimenting with germ welfare warfare
Throughout the US they were doing different studies
They were trying to create and did create a kid's or virus
And that's a whole discussion in itself
but
these uh
The theory goes that they created a bacteria from morphine and other bacteria
And they were going to use a maybe possibly a tick at that time as an intermediate host
And the thought was that they could fly over a country drop all these ticks that would then
You know affect the people and people would die. You know, I don't really fully understand
What was going through the minds of our leadership in this country when you're talking about germ warfare because
If you're going to create a disease that's going to kill millions and millions of people and bring your enemy to their knees
Was there thought that oh, we could just denoculate
Our people with the vaccination that they're going to be immune to that disease
So none of our people are going to die but all their people are going to die. It's insanity
So
But this understand we have to understand the culture of the Cold War the there was such unbelievable fear
That the the US was going to be nuked by a russia
Advice a versa
so
To we kind of got to give them a little understanding the of the fear that was involved
Now the US certainly was not the only country that was
Experimented with crazy different ways to kill human beings
During that time russia was at the same time. So
We'll go more to that into the theories of that of how Lyme disease started and some
Some in some more in depth presentations in the future
But I just wanted to kind of give you an overview. It was in the 1980s that this
sciatist really named the
uh
Borrelia burgodorphy
He was one who discovered it and it was named after him
We know though that there's
There's dozens and dozens and dozens of co-infect co-infections that go along with that
Uh, so when a person has this type of
Graham negative bacteria
There's other things that they also have that go along with that
In the early 2000s. That's when at least the CDC started to recognize it
The four years they were just basically brushing it under the rug and
Pretending that it didn't even exist even to this day. They still fail to recognize chronic Lyme disease
Which which in itself for as I look at different dumb
the kind of
Conspiracy theory
Origins of Lyme disease. It makes me start to believe that they may be true
Given the fact that the CDC is totally willing and so as every pharmaceutical company
Is willing to jump on a new disease that they could
Make money off of that effect. You can't listen to a commercial on television
Pharmaceutical commercial where they're making up a new disease constantly
and
Because they have a new drug for it
Why would they jump on Lyme disease? There has to be some political connection where
Maybe if they did jump on chronic Lyme disease there'd have to be a greater investigation into the cause and they
It would be it wouldn't be a good thing if everybody really knew where it came from
I don't know maybe it was they're protecting
Lawsuth. I have no idea. It just seems very strange that doctors are being persecuted for treating the chronic Lyme disease and states have to
Have citizens you know bring petitions to their lawmakers to to give doctors a freedom
Rights to treat chronic Lyme disease. It just makes no sense to me. So
There's something political behind the scenes
Hush hush about the whole thing. It's just a it's a very sad situation for a lot of Lyme sufferers
Especially when you're dealing with acute Lyme and I have patients that call me all the time
What what should I do get some antibiotics? My doctor won't give me any antibiotics because the tests came back negative
Even though I had this huge bulls-eye rash and I have these flu symptoms
It's insanity. It's absolute insanity. How few doctors know anything about Lyme disease
You know they're the
The clinics in the hospitals are basically telling the doctors that it doesn't exist. There's something political going on
Today it is one of the fastest-growing vector
Board infections in the United States
The CDC estimates that there are over 300,000 new cases each year in the US now if so few of them are being diagnosed
And they're saying 300,000 that's a scary number. That's really possible out there
It could be in the millions of people that are being infected with Lyme disease every year
It is uh
It is not you know you look at some maps. I didn't post any of this
presentation, but Lyme disease really started the Eastern country now. It's literally in every state
According to the recent research not yet in Hawaii, but there's probably Lyme cases in Hawaii, you know
It is a it's insane how fast it's spreading if in fact the government did produce this this uh bacteria
In experimentation it is a one sad situation
And understandably why they'd want to cover it up
So why is it such a problem treating Lyme?
The biggest thing is that Lyme hides
So Lyme disease the
Borrelia burgodorophy bacteria is a gram-negative bacteria
If you listen to any way other talks, we talk about different types of bacteria
They're gram positive and gram-negative bacteria, gram-negative bacteria. There's other classifications
But this gram-negative bacteria is different than other bacteria
Uh, how the cell membrane is made up
This gram-negative bacteria have what's called a lipopolysaccharide in the cell membrane
gram-negative bacteria also have the ability
Uh, not all of them, but some of them have the ability to go inside of a cell and hide inside the cell
Now this makes it very unique. Viruses go inside the cell. That's how they replicate
Typically bacteria do not go inside the cell
So when you give somebody an antibiotic, you're able to eradicate the bacteria
When you give somebody an antibiotic that has a virus, you're not able to eradicate the virus
Uh, antibiotics do nothing against virus
Viruses are hiding inside the cell. That's how they live. They don't just live in the bloodstream of the host
They go intracellular
So it is with some of the gram-negative bacteria Lyme be one of them
It has the ability to infiltrate the cell and hide inside the cell
If it hides inside the cell, then the immune, then your number, your immune system can't kill it
Because it's inside the cell and your uh, uh, an antibiotic can't kill it
So you have to catch it while it's still
Extracellular while it's still in the bloodstream
If you're going to kill it with uh, antibiotic
Now normally if a virus infiltrates the cell, the cell actually puts up a marker on the outside of the cell
Telling your immune system that it has been invaded
So when the immune system sees this marker outside the cell, the immune system will actually engulf that cell
And destroy that entire cell killing the virus inside the cell as well
So it can't replicate. That's how your body kills viruses
Now if a cell has been infiltrated, that marker should, that's a little uh,
Pro-T marker that that the cell gives off so that the immune system can tell that it's been invaded
Lyme disease has the ability to disable that marker
So though the, the, the burrelia bacteria is inside the cell and the immune system doesn't know it
So the immune system can't find it, can't kill it
It's looking for this enemy that it that that was located in this area
And now it's got circulating immune cells trying to kill this bacteria and it can't find it
Well, you're going to learn when we get to understand what stage three
Autoimmune Lyme disease is that could be a huge problem because my immune system
Is like the US Marine Corps they are not going to give up until they find that
Intention that enemy and they will actually start creating enemies out of their own self-tissue
If they can't find the enemy and that's when the person has
Very very debilitating symptoms
So we'll get to that so just hold on but the biggest problem with trading Lyme is that Lyme hides in tracelular
This is kind of a neat little slide and there's some studies done on root canals
So root canals were tested for burrelia
Now if you have a whole presentation of the negative things about root canals
But the problem with a root canal is that the root canal in itself you have this
Diode tooth that is super painful because it's infected so the purpose of a root canals
We're going to drill through the tooth get to the core of the tooth
We're going to dig out the blood supply and the nerve supply
And then fill it in and pack it in with whatever filling we're going to put in there
And now you still have this pretty tooth that you can chew things with
But it's a completely dead tooth
Now if you looked well you think that's a good thing great
No, I don't have any paint anymore
Now I still have my tooth. I don't have a hole in my
In my gum and
Life goes on
But the problem is a tooth
Is a porous
material if we could take a tooth and put it under a microscope
It has all these little pores inside there
It's actually a living organism your tooth is it's a part of your body similar to bone
Just because it's dead doesn't mean it's not living
So a tooth is a living thing and you took out the blood supply you took out the nerve supply
And now basically you have a
You have a hotel for bacteria
So bacteria can stay in that root canal
Tooth live in that tooth
Even if you took a lot of antibiotics even if you smeared antibiotics on that tooth
And you took a whole bunch of herbals as you did all the things right
There's no they can't penetrate the tooth because there's no blood supply to the tooth left
You did a root canal on it and removed it all
So bacteria can house in that tooth
So as soon as your immune system drops down a little bit
They go out of the tooth start replicating they start infected your body
Then your immune system kicks on to kill it
And the ones that are still in the tooth are still hiding in the tooth
So oh it's a nasty thing
So a root canal could be the cause of a person's chronic infection
Now when I say cause it's not really the cause
It's the hotel that the chronic infection can hide in and live there
So as soon as your immune system drops a little bit
They take off and it makes you really sick
You fire an immune response
You might kill off the stuff that's in the blood
If you have a healthy immune system you continue to do that
Continue to do that continue to do that
And all sorts of bad things can happen
One being an autoimmune disease too
Second reason why it's hard to treat is that
Few people understand the Lyme stages
Few doctors that you go to understand any stages of Lyme disease
They'll take a patient that
Has Lyme symptoms
Going on for five or six months and they'll put them on antibiotics
Well, Dr. Sicily is going to do very little
For a person's Lyme symptoms
After they are beyond that acute stage
It will help their symptoms for a short period of time
Because it will kill anything that is extra cellular
But it's not going to do anything for the
Spiracates that are in trust cellular within the cell
And so while they're taking the antibiotic
They feel a little bit better
Possibly and as soon as they go off
Their symptoms start to come back
Because you can't kill the bacteria
That's inside the cell
So if you don't understand the different stages of Lyme disease
It makes it more difficult to treat
And last few are still understand
That the third stage that I speak about
I know there's a lot of writing about Lyme disease
So what you're going to hear from me
Is going to be different
So there's writing about Lyme disease
That talks about two stages
Or talks about three stages
You're going to get over and over again
What my definition of this three stages
Are three phases of Lyme disease
Are the third phase in my book
Is it's moved to an autoimmune disease
So I'm going to get that hard and heavy
What an autoimmune disease is
It is your immune system attacking yourself
Tissue because it was looking for the antigen
Antigen in an immune response
Is anything that the immune system is
Turned on against
To this case
The birelli and its co-infections
And now it's attacking self tissue
So we'll get into that in depth
So hold your horses
And we'll talk about that
Take home from this
Is that treat acute Lyme disease
As soon as possible with antibiotics
We're going to talk more about that
With the next presentation
That you'll get next week
And if you do not get fairly instantaneous relief
Of your fever, chills, rash, etc
By taking antibiotics
You probably missed the window
So you can always call our office for help
Remember if you have questions
You know we see people from all over the world
With Lyme disease and cancer
So we're always here to help
All right, I hope this help
We're going to be going deeper and deeper
As we go
This is all due to you
Let's do it again
And
We'll talk to you soon
Bye bye